Check out this trade right here. I'm up
over $4,000 in just 20 minutes. All
because of one specific pattern I use to
confirm super accurate entries, and it's
right here. This pattern doesn't just
help me find solid entries. It also
allows me to risk a small amount for a
high reward, just like this trade. I
consistently find setups like this,
trading just 60 minutes each morning. In
a minute, I'll break down this entire
trade step by step. But first, let me
show you the exact pattern I use to
confirm the trade entry and how you can
consistently use it yourself. So, what
this pattern should look like when you
are betting that the market is going to
continue going lower is that it should
have multiple bullish candles like you
see here into a very large bearish
candlestick. And the whole reason behind
this and why it's important is it
because it shows you a shift in
momentum. There's a clear methodical
move higher and then a clear massive
break and switch of momentum to the
downside. And this can really be the
first domino of either continuing a
trend lower or if the market was coming
up in an uptrend, it can be the first
domino in switching to a downtrend. So
either you can use it as a continuation
pattern or as a reversal pattern. Now
this is just kind of what it should show
up and look like while you are you know
kind of at the drawing board. The
reality of what this can look like
sometimes is a little bit different.
This is from an actual chart. What it
can look like is the candles can still
be kind of all over the place. But the
idea is what you want to look for is
kind of a a clean methodical trend up.
It's starting to kind of even some
slowishness here. some dogeis that's
totally okay. And then always you want
to see a big switch in momentum. Well,
one because it happens in a big
candlestick that means there's an
increase in momentum. So that means it's
more likely that big players are coming
in and they're going to this is going to
be the start of a big trend shift or a
continuation with the major trend if
this is just a pullback move. And it
also takes out and is much larger than
these previous candlesticks. This is
kind of some in keys to this pattern is
that it takes out three to five of the
previous candlesticks. That's the big
key here is that you want this
candlestick to be much larger. And when
you're confirming to use it is always
wait for the candlestick to close and
finish forming. You don't want to see a
candlestick look like this and say, you
know, oh, it's showing a massive move in
momentum. I got to get in now because as
this candle is forming, it could move
down a ton and you could be worried that
it just continues lower, right? And you
want to get in quick. FOMO comes in, but
instead you need to wait for it to close
because otherwise what it could happen
is it could come down here and then it
could come back up and it could make a
candle that looks completely different.
And it could make something like this in
the opposite direction where you know it
the candlestick looks like this and
instead you entered in you know
somewhere down here and now it looks
really really crappy. And at that point
the pattern hasn't actually finished
forming and so you need to wait for the
candlestick to always finish forming.
And so this pattern is called the
threeline strike pattern. And you can
use it in either direction. You can use
it in a bullish or bearish way that we
just looked at. For bullish, it's
literally just the same thing, just in
the opposite. You have a couple
candlesticks moving down and then you
have that big switch of momentum.
Essentially like this, the same thing.
There's clean, methodical move down. The
market's kind of in a nice chill
downtrend, and then all of a sudden,
boom, you have a massive switch of
momentum. Just get in long right above
this candlestick at the close. And I
like to put my stop loss below that
swing. That's kind of the key area to
put it just because if the market comes
all the way back here, it's likely that
it's going to continue lower and you
just want to cut your losses at that
point. That's how I get those accurate
entries for a high reward and lowrisk
kind of setup. Now, some unimportant
factors about this is, you know, the
candlesticks like these ones. They're a
lot more dogey like they're not like
this pattern. The main thing is what
you're looking for is a loss of momentum
or a clean slow methodical move of
momentum and then a massive switch. And
then as well another thing is you can
see this low right here is actually
lower than the candlestick right here.
It doesn't matter if this main
candlestick is the actual low or bottom.
The main thing is you know again looking
for that kind of slow methodical
movement and then massive switch in
momentum. And you can see this in
actually another pattern I have here is
a trap. This is a perfect example right
here of a really nice threeline strike
pattern where you can see the market
went up here really really consistently
and then boom, you have a massive switch
in momentum. And what you want to do
with these is you want to use them at
key areas of like resistance levels. You
don't want to just be blindly using this
by itself. You need to be coupling it
with a couple other factors. Now, what
I've been walking through here is a
whole downloadable guide and PDF that
you can get in the link in the
description of this video or through
this QR code. Okay, so now let's look at
some real examples so you can actually
take this to your own trading. So, first
off, here is a great example of using a
threeline strike for an entry with a
couple of other patterns. Basically
right here, this threeline strike
pattern that's happening right now is
confirming a double top coming in. All I
like to use these for are reversal
trades. You can use them for
continuation trades as well, but I like
to use them for reversal trades. And you
can see here the markets come up and
it's made uh one top and then
essentially you can see we had momentum
and then look at these multiple
candlesticks right here. We start to
slow down. you know, we've kind of come
up here, right? There hasn't been any
bearishness and then all of a sudden,
boom, we have a massive candlestick
right here, showing that switch in
momentum that, okay, you know,
especially with being at this double top
in that same area. You're essentially
confirming that double top, which is
even better and makes it more likely
that this is a good area to enter in on
a threeline strike pattern. And so, I
like to enter in at the break of that
low. This is trading a one minute chart.
The candlesticks right after are pulling
back slightly. And I actually think that
is a even better confirmation if the
market pulls back a little bit and then
continues lower and it doesn't break the
high of that threeline strike pattern.
So if I just zoom in a little bit more
to let this kind of play out. I put in
an entry here right as it breaks below
that threeline strike pattern and then I
put my stop up here above the double
top. If the mark comes up here and I'm
wrong, just get out. You know, the idea
of this is you are entering in really
accurately at the highs and you're
looking for, you know, capturing a whole
swing lower. And so just to kind of
watch this trade played out, you can see
from there it kind of moved all the way
lower and kind of hit a target that I
was looking for more towards the lows.
And so I closed up at about $600 and it
gave a perfect signal at the highs to
get in and then from there I was able to
ride the swing lower and capture a
really nice trade. Here's another
example and this is on the flip side
looking for a long. You can see clearly
I'm looking at a support level here
where the market's bounced once, twice.
There was probably another bounce here
before on the previous area in the chart
that I was looking at. And so I'm
already looking for the big picture of
the market to come down here and bounce.
And to accurately enter and confirm that
the market's going to bounce here is I
looked for the market to make a
essentially it slowed down here and then
it had a strong bullish candlestick
here. form and I got in essentially as
it was about to finish closing. I got in
a couple seconds earlier, but I
essentially got in as it created that
threeline strike pattern. And you can
see here it was actually a candlestick
after the bottom here. It wasn't right
away, but it was still showing me that
switch in momentum. and it gave me an
accurate entry to enter in at the bottom
of the swing, have a tighter stop-loss,
and then capture the reversal back
higher. And so, this is super super
powerful for capturing trades like this.
You know, every trade is going to go
slightly different. We're going to go
over that massive one here in a minute,
but this is still a really nice trade to
capture, you know, $400 or $500 worth of
profit. Again, just trading 60 minutes
in the morning. And so, at that point,
you know, the market kind of slowed
down. I said, "Okay, I want to get out
if it breaks lower because it could just
give that swing back up." And that's
where I kind of got out at about $400
and moved on with my day. If you've been
wondering what platform I'm using here,
it's called Ninja Trader. And you can
actually start trading with live data
for free, which most platforms actually
charge for right away. The desktop
platform, which I'm using, is super
customizable, and I've actually made my
own custom indicators for it. But if
you're more into using either the
web-based version or the mobile version,
those are really, really good as well.
Now, to go over this trade that I
started out in the beginning of the
video and kind of just show you, walk
through managing this trade and also how
to enter and confirm using this strategy
a little bit more than I've already gone
into. Let me walk you through how I
entered and found this trade. And so
initially what I'm seeing is you can see
that the market had a nice methodical
trend up here and then this bearishness
right here showed me that okay
something's changed. We've broken this
uptrend. That's a massive thing that I
like to look for. And then also this big
trend line right here is drawn from a
bigger picture where on a 15 or 5 minute
I can see that the market consistently
is coming up to this level. It comes up
here again it's likely to continue
lower. Obviously, if I see the threeline
strike pattern that I like to see and a
couple of other factors and so seeing
that it had this big bearishness here,
that was a great confirmation to say,
okay, the momentum in this market is
switching, you always want to take that
into account. You want to have a big
picture idea of where the market is
going. If you're either using this, you
can see right here, here's a great
example of using the threeline strike
pattern for a long is there's this nice
upwards trend line. The market comes
down to the trend line, it chops there
for a couple candlesticks and then boom,
you have a massive switch in the
momentum continuing it higher and you
would confirm and use that right here
because you're seeing an uptrend already
in place. You would already drawn that
uptrend off of those three lows,
extended it, assume that well the market
comes down here and gives me a threeline
strike pattern. I'm going to bet the
market's going to go up. You would have
got in here and captured a nice move
after that. But once it comes up to this
trend line, which is a big picture
downtrend line, well, you got to think
of it in the flip side. I think that
this is more likely to push the market
lower. And so I need to make sure that
this shorter term trend is broken, which
happened right here. And that this
bigger picture is going to continue and
take into effect again. And so then the
market broke down here. That's why I
didn't get in up here. You could kind of
say there's a threeline strike pattern
here. That for me was a little too
aggressive. I like to wait for a little
bit more confirmation. We came down
here, had a little bit of a bounce,
showed, you know, some momentum.
Essentially, you could even say this is
a 50% pullback from this area. You can
see it's literally in the middle of that
box. The market likes to do pullbacks
like that that are literally halfway of
the move it just had. And so, it moved
down this far, it pulled back halfway,
that's what this little spike here is,
and then it sold off. And for me, this
isn't a super picture perfect and really
nice looking threeline strike pattern,
but for me, I saw, you know, okay,
there's some movement up here. There's
this big attempt to go higher and then,
you know, it's essentially in this
little mini channel and then this big
candlestick here, especially with the
fact that it wicks higher right here.
This little wick right here, it's it's
essentially like a micro double top. And
then I get in, you know, I I actually
got in down here a little bit because it
was moving pretty quickly, but the
signal there is at the candlestick close
right there. And so that's what I used
to jump in on this and then of course
put the stop up here. Doesn't need to go
all the way up here above this trend
line. You know, what we're trying to do
is risk a tight amount and then have the
big picture potential for the market to
really start moving in our favor. And so
in this trade, I think I'm risking like
$500. The last couple trades were
smaller size, but you know, that's why
you can use this kind of in any account
size. You can scale it up because again,
trading is super scalable. You just use
and find one pattern that works and then
increase the money. You don't need to
try and find more patterns to make more
trades. That's what kind of kept me from
being profitable initially. And so
you'll see here actually once the market
essentially made a pullback here right
here and then moved down, I moved my
stop loss to break even because I want
to kind of tighten up the trade and get
out if it's going to pull back on me.
You know, sometimes the market's just
going to be choppy all over the place. I
don't want to trade in that. I want to
be in trades and I've noticed these
trades will work out pretty cleanly in
your favor if they're going to work out.
And so from there, you know, it starts
moving down pretty quickly. I'm trying
to see, okay, is there this downtrend
line that I can kind of expect the
market to pull back to? And again,
that's kind of thinking about, okay, how
am I managing this? You know, as you are
trading, you want to be thinking what to
do next based on logic, not okay, I'm
up, you know, almost
$3,000. Uh, you know, I'm really
nervous. This is a lot of money. I need
to get out or what if this keeps going,
I could be up 5,000, 10,000. Right? You
can't let your emotions kind of control
what you do. you need to have a logical
plan to trade with. And so once this
kind of got rocketing in one direction,
it gets really far away from the trend
line and I don't want to hold through a
pullback. You know, at this point that's
a big pullback to hold through for it
breaking that trend line. And so I start
using kind of more of a tighter trailing
stop-loss with kind of previous
candlestick highs. And you can also see
there is this blue box down here. That's
a support level. And so big picture,
I've looked at, okay, well, the market's
already bounced here a couple times. If
we come down here again, I'm going to
expect that we're going to bounce or
slow down. And this is a really fastm
moving, unhealthy move, which is great
to be in if you're in it, but it's
likely to snap back at some point. And I
want to be out when it's going to snap
back. And so that's why I have kind of a
tighter trailing stop-loss. And you can
see it's starting to snap back a little
bit. And I want to give it a little
wiggle room because, you know, these
things can break through a support level
and keep going lower. But in this case,
it kind of starts to chop here. It makes
a double bottom and it essentially
knocks me out here. But I get, you know,
about $3,500, $3,200 worth of profit.
Now, make sure you get my free 14page
strategy guide that'll walk you through
a ton more patterns that I use to
consistently find entries. You can
download it in the link in the
description or using this QR code. And
the other thing that's really important
for my strategies is support and
resistance levels. You need to be using
the correct tools to find accurate
support and resistance levels. And in
this video right here, I'm going to walk
you through the five keys that I use
every day.